i hope you've been taking swimming
lessons ladies and gentlemen it's been
almost two years since the season of
american horror story has come out and
we have our first glimpse at season 10
double feature part 1 red tide i'm not
going to be wasting any time we're going
to be taking a deep dive pardon the pun
into the latest trailer and seeing what
clues it offers but before we begin if
you haven't seen the trailer i've left a
link in the description below and make
sure to like and subscribe because i'm
hoping to break down every episode of
the season so let's get into it right
off the bat we can see the provincetown
massachusetts pier at low tide i'm
pretty sure it's this thing over here
but if anyone is familiar with
provincetown let me know in the comments
and here is the provincetown sign and
what i really love here is the date 1686
now the official founding of the city
was 1727 but it was also the site where
the pilgrims landed from the mayflower
way back in 1620 so there's a lot of
history here and if there's anything we
know about american horror story is that
they love to do flashbacks and this
trailer even hints at some the tie-in
with the pilgrims here also means we
could be getting some crossover with
season six's roanoke colony even though
that was said in northern virginia this
whole idea of older colonies could come
into play here we get our first glimpse
of the main character of part 1 finn wit
rock's harry gardner in the youtube
trailer description it says this season
focuses around a struggling writer harry
his pregnant wife here we see lily ray
visibly pregnant she plays doris gardner
and their daughter alma moving into a
secluded seaside town for the winter
partially blocked by the lights we can
see what appears to be someone showing
them the home but i'm not convinced it's
any of the main cast this seems to be a
fresh start for the family and for harry
who wants to finish his work without
distractions in this shot it looks like
doris is busy with redecorating the
place and rightly so it's pretty drab
she has all these different kinds of
swatches and it looks like she can't
make a decision between white and
slightly off-white take a look at this
shot of a man's hands playing the piano
this is followed by some sheet music
here and you can barely make out some
piano keys on the bottom as the camera
reveals evan peter's character austin
who is using his martini shaker like a
maraca notice here that the piano hands
seem older so this is likely not his
character rather a pianist at one of the
local bars or restaurants we'll see
later austin is also a writer a writer
of music and we can hear him in the
voiceover talking about how this place
is inspiring another shot of the town at
low tide and a blank laptop screen as
harry struggles with inspiration
voiceover plays from the bar scene where
it looks like he's conversing with
austin and frances conroy's character
belle noire we don't know much about
belle but it's possible she's an artist
as well and as we'll see later in this
trailer harry gets into some sort of
trouble with them here we have alma
playing the violin the bow has been
hinted at in a previous trailer and
considering the cases ominously a
crimson red it could play a larger role
in the season no real significance of
the composer leopold godowski that i can
see yet he was a famous russian-american
piano player so it looks like music may
play a large role in this season and
here we get our first look at angelica
ross's character the chemist we'll later
see her creating these black pills in a
lab in the promotional posters we've
seen these black pills with the aliens
and sea creatures this might be
something that ties both parts of double
feature together harry suffers from
writer's block which austin says won't
last long here and just a few shots
later we see harry starting what appears
to be a screenplay to the left is a book
called land's end a book about
provincetown by pulitzer prize-winning
author michael cunningham here's a
cemetery which will see alma overlooking
a tombstone for a soldier named brandon
newman from 1775. this appears to be her
mother behind her as it looks like the
same coat we saw her wearing when she
entered the home onward to leslie
grossman's character ursula a kind of
interesting name since ursula is the
name of the villain in the little
mermaid and considering this part of
double features centers around the sea
it's a very purposeful name choice she's
sitting across from ahs newcomer
macaulay culkin in the same bar we saw
harry in we can tell by the picture in
the background and mccully who plays a
character named mickey seems extremely
apprehensive at helping ursula find out
what weird occurrences are happening
here judging by this set photo here it
looks like ursula is extremely rich more
alma violin footage and harry typing
away his writer's block looks to have
been overcome we get some more voice
over of belle noire's character which by
the way her name translates to beautiful
black from french i wonder if there's
any relation to the black pill in her vo
she says success is addictive once you
get a taste of it this is followed by a
rack focused shot of harry looking at
his wife's bloody finger it's a little
too early to say but i got mad vampire
vibes here especially after belle noire
says of success quote you'll never be
able to live without it substitute
success for blood and you have some sort
of vampire creature here we have a gun
being pulled on harry this is likely
what gets him involved in that scene
where belle noire slits someone's throat
now this might tie into the woman with
her throat slit here if i were to hazard
a guest this looks to be adena porter's
character chief burleson as we can make
out what could be a provincetown police
department emblem on the side here and
now we have the queen herself sarah
paulson's character tb karen in an
interview paulson stated she had the
best name character ever so i think
they're holding off on what tb actually
stands for and i'm curious if her
character is literally one of those
entitled cairns as the show often pokes
fun at pop culture tv karen is not
looking good here it's almost as though
her eyes are bruised and she is running
away from something or someone we get
some voiceover of doris saying we're not
safe here followed by dennis o'hare's
character harold stumbling upon a
severed hand and foot the hand here has
a distinct r ring now i've gone through
the whole trailer and haven't been able
to match it with a character nor is
there a character with a first or last
name that starts with the letter r my
guess this is someone we haven't met yet
doris walks with a knife in her home and
opens the door to find what appears to
be her daughter we only get this tiny
one frame glimpse the next shot is of
the pale creature at least that's what
they've called it in the imdb credits
probably somehow related to these things
we've seen in the posters by the looks
of things this dude is attacking the
town bar now we get a shot of what could
be a female pale creature we know there
is a female actress who plays one
according to imdb here we're at the
graveyard and it leads me to believe
these two might be looking for one
another is it possible there's a
connection to that gravestone we saw
alma looking at earlier here we have
mickey's character looking like he's
breaking into a home so role reversal
from home alone the wallpaper and
stained glass suggests this is not
harry's home but likely bell noirs if
that's true it means that belle noire
may hold the secret to what ursula is
looking for alma tells her mother that
it takes pain to make beautiful things
and in the next shot we see what looks
to be doris taking alma's violin will
she smash it place your bets now now
this shot here has been the most
difficult to decipher we have a bloody
harry in some sort of basement with what
appears to be an unconscious or dead
body and he's holding a gun to someone
it's also just a very odd choice of
clothing for the winter and a cold
basement he's also not wearing any shoes
we just don't have enough info to make
any huge claims just yet but if i were
to take a guess the dude on the floor is
someone we haven't met and he's pointing
the gun at bell noir also there's a
power saw and some chains in the back
it's possible someone here was chained
up we also get our first shot of billy
lord's character lark another odd name
she seems to be some sort of dentist and
if you pay close attention here you can
see harry's tooth chipped almost
fang-like and in the posters you'll have
seen these fang-like teeth just why he
needs his teeth like this who knows here
we have what appears to be a man with a
hair bun opening the door to bell austin
and harry and harry doesn't look like
he's going to enjoy what's about to
happen we have mickey being embraced by
who i think is tb karen the look on
mickey's face suggests it's either an
unexpected hug or he's getting stabbed
and since it occurs right before this
shot of tv walking away from a dead body
all bloodied i think they want us to
believe that's what happened but i think
it's a fake out no took seems to be a
different overcoat i'm inclined to
believe that these are two separate
scenes and that isn't mickey's body on
the beach let's also talk about the
blood on tb's face did she straight up
bite or eat that dude in the background
the show has already hinted at
bloodthirsty creatures so let me know
what you think in the comments below
another shot of that pale creature at
first i thought this might be on the
beach but then i saw the arrow sign in
the top left showing that it's concrete
we have another shot of the cemetery
with the pale man and a woman getting
down on her knees notice here the
bouquet of flowers he holds could this
be from her is he leaving them on a
grave where his lover is and is this
woman here getting down on her knees to
beg or is she just insanely happy to see
him our last shot is of doris in labor
suggesting that part one might climax
with the birth of their child and this
child will likely play a large role in
the events of the season you don't just
make a character pregnant for fun unless
it somehow ties into the narrative so
those are the major things i picked out
of this trailer i hope you're excited
for the season as much as i am i want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below and before you go make
sure to like and subscribe i'm always
coming out with new ahs videos you can
also follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much